oh don't run my game it's real bad
welcome to I don't have a name for this
I'm opening a bunch mails about scaring
my god sensei and it's not open bro mail
bro man that I got at my pew box and if
I don't open if you don't see your mail
being open in this episode then net hey
there don't worry I got so many so there
will be more and first one is from
Camille Thomas Camille you are a lucky
girl or boy I don't know if Thomas your
last name or Camille is your first name
it's a really out parry
oh parody you're so far away Oh Perry
help Erie I wish I can see something I
know why it sound like I'm stalker but
I'm just a walker oh my friend told me
about you and a doubts you would be
funny
why would you jump jack you start up
nothing nothing bro
brother but it turned out that I was a
dummy when I heard all this weird name
thought oh great he is saying that's
like everyone's first impression on me
for whatever I don't get out of get that
really awesome letter
thank you a lot I I will save this
finishes reading later if I don't finish
I don't I don't have a lot of that much
time I don't like making videos for like
20 minutes where is this hair
I don't know what you read that kind of
a hammer opieop her hair and oh thank
God it's not come on it's such an
initial over the hell are you bro
sending me I dude what the hell is this
oh yeah ask at its site okay this it's
like a so long I think it's a llama
what do you breasts think is it the hell
are you talking yes I have legs I know a
lot of people are impressed
who is it from it's from Alyssa so thank
you listen be a snake then she's really
good at drawing - it's pretty cool I'll
show you at the cool ladder thank you
eat up Beauty you're great
brofist from Marcus Marcus Marcus and he
drew a piggy with her little nose in it
in his and there we go we got the lady
he's like shove lady you looking fine
she's not that fine about this I mean
fun all right
some candy Maura try to do it you send
me barrel candy
goddamn you barrows okay you're doing
her skin two of them I'm chewing the
[ __ ] out of action on this one is from
young sting huh from the states
he's an artist I can tell ray whoa it's
be PBJ time all right
that's a bunch of freakin barrels and
I'm hiding in one of the barrels just
you know why not pewdiepie bro bro bro I
have to tell you something bro your
girlfriend is hot why thank you
I'm glad you just wrote me a mail mm bet
he's also thinking but dunker green
thank you down to green awesome painting
the same your brochure talented should
be open a package haha alright first off
it's a beautiful painting of Ione and
the bro and it's from Julius funhouse
move damn that's a badass name man or
boy
Julius oh that really your name as an
awesome painting I hope I can zoom it in
cuz I'm too lazy to move and then bring
it yeah a pawn a jump ring and pop shop
what are you besides a stupid chub bro
Geoffrey can pump yeah oh you looking
sexy that really oh I like that so bad
I'm doing this then well I'm not doing
it it has like batteries and stuff in it
should I try it oh well piggy I'll let
you sit over here
thank see yourself
Paxton bike free thank you
all right letter from Noah and Dobson
hey Pete vibe you know my name is Noah
and my brother is Jonah 10 we watch your
videos every day on YouTube yes if you
this is a picture they take the place
run Barry run
Liam why is everyone so pretty good at
drawing
okay look at that look at it's awesome
brofist - Noah and Jonah fan thinking
breath OH
roses are red violets are blue I'm a
stone that's [ __ ] you hello what did you
say what the hell that's not cold yet
fire it's from Robyn dragon awesome man
- you peed by Felix I hope you like the
picture I'm your number one fan
Rauf is robbing your are freaking
talented and drawing man thank you both
all these I'm I'm gonna make so far by
all that all these pictures and drawings
are urban educated I'm really happy
it makes me really glad to see there's
another it's from Lisa Hanson it's
supposed to be like the live stream and
everyone and everyone is writing watch
out he's in the back room freaking
awesome and then
and she also made a picture for my
school she pushes all my stencil
different salons last day a couple days
ago I someone knocked on the door and I
hope and this was laying outside its
what is baby what are you doing here but
I don't know what if it's just like a
miniature or you can open the doors why
got tried it bit okay I was put him in
the background maybe but it's booth hey
hey you drunk with nothing yeah I
partied too hard that's why yeah sit
down man
- done alright lay down whatever next
one is from oj I think it's from Oh
James Knox awesome photo I hope you can
see it I'm too lazy to get up sometimes
then hand Leonardo's sat me and boy
that's a badass name bro
I wouldn't mind not being called
Leonardo CNN I would be like suck
[ __ ] I'm really not a real seaman
it's a book it's a bird cuz why not
and it says Stefano and it's a bad
drawing look I love you okay dad then
awesome going what are you talking about
the father is very photogenic I gotta
say this one is from sister Seth and
he's from cancer and he says I'm the
most awesome youtuber ever and he wants
a major brofist
so think about stuff I really appreciate
it here's your Broca's man just for you
little big one
I wonder what this could be it's from
New York Slovak club IKEA that's
Christmas paper wrapped in but whatever
dear Felix thank you for all the time
you spend making awesome play please I
really enjoy them doing long and boring
nights that's really awesome thank you
bro
here you go to his name breakfast to you
man let's see what it's sent you again
no way Maura what are you doing behind
what what you're really good bro look at
this it's like a miniature that's the
real grass on it and stuff
think of me it's Bailey got a miniature
bro can you see that it's also has a
battle and everything
damn thank you bro I really appreciate
it all right next one is from Nivea my
life
you Brooke what's so everyone have it
like badass name who lives
internationally I think really good oh
we got a crayon boss right here but you
got bad ass okay I guess this is me or
him I don't know but it's pretty damn
bad ash pinche bro freaking a lot - all
right I'll become bruh I realized the
camera ran out of battery plus the
stupid microphone didn't work either I
think your microphone for trolling me
and anyway I want to thank you bros for
all the awesome mail I really appreciate
it it's really cool you taking the time
and money to send me stuff
um but yeah that's pretty much it's a
lot of brofist and say awesomer
also I realize I got to try one of these
barrel of candies before I before I am
this doesn't look very good I'm here on
it all right
Wow